when uh was spot born
around
2000 and uh 12 or so
so again almost 10 years into sort of a
run with DARPA where we built a bunch of
different quadrupeds we had a sort of a
different thread where we started
building humanoids
um we we saw that probably an end was
coming where the government was going to
kind of back off from a lot of Robotics
investment
and uh
in order to maintain progress we just
deduced that well we probably need to
sell ourselves to somebody who wants to
continue to invest in this this area and
that was Google
and so
um at Google we would meet regularly
with Larry Page and Larry just started
asking us you know what's your product
going to be and you know the logical
thing the thing that we had the most
history with that we wanted to continue
developing was our quadruped but we knew
it needed to be smaller we knew it
couldn't have a gas engine we thought it
probably couldn't be hydraulically
actuated
so that began the process of exploring
if we could migrate to a smaller
electrically actuated
robot and that was really the Genesis of
spot
so not a gas engine and the actuators
are electric yes so can you maybe
comment on what it's like
um my Google working with Larry Page
having those meetings and thinking of
what will a robot look like
that could be
built that scale what like starting to
think about a product
Larry always liked the the toothbrush
test he wanted products that you used
every day
um
what they really wanted was
you know a consumer level product
something that would work in your house
we didn't think that was the right next
thing to do because to be a consumer
level product cost is going to be very
important
probably needed to cost a few thousand
dollars and we were we were building
these machines that cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars maybe a million
dollars to build of course we were only
building a two but
but we didn't see how to get all the way
to this consumer level product in a
short amount in a short amount of time
and he suggested that we we make the
robots really inexpensive
and part of our philosophy has always
been
build the best hardware you can
make make the machine operate well
so that you're trying to solve
you know discover the the hard problem
that you don't know about don't don't
make it harder by by building a crappy
machine basically you build the best
machine you can there's plenty of hard
problems to solve that are going to have
to do with you know under actuated
systems and balance
and so we wanted to build these high
quality machines still and we thought
that was important for us to continue
learning about really what was the
important parts of the make robots work
um and so there was a little bit of a
philosophical difference there that we
and and so ultimately that's why we're
building robots for the industrial
sector now because the industry can
afford a more expensive machine because
you know their productivity depends on
keeping their Factory going and so if
spot costs you know a hundred thousand
dollars or more that's not such a big
expense to them whereas at the consumer
level no one's going to buy a robot like
that and I think we might eventually get
to a consumer level product that will be
that cheap but I think the path to
getting there needs to go through these
really nice machines so we can then
learn how to simplify
so what can you say to the almost the
engineering challenge of bringing down
costs
of a robot so that presumably when you
try to build the robot at scale that
also comes into play when you're trying
to make money on a robot even in in the
industrial setting but how interesting
how challenging
of of a thing is that in particular
probably new to an r d company yeah I'm
glad you brought that last part up the
transition from an r d company to a
commercial company
that's the thing you worry about you
know because you've got these Engineers
who love hard problems who want to
figure out how to make robots work and
you don't know if you have Engineers
that want to work on the quality and
reliability and costs that is ultimately
required
um and indeed you know we have brought
on a lot of new people who are inspired
by those problems
but but the big takeaway lesson for me
is
we have good people we have Engineers
who want to solve problems and and the
quality and cost and manufacturability
is just another kind of problem
and because they're so invested in what
we're doing they're interested in and
we'll go work on on those problems as
well and so I think we're managing that
transition very well in fact I'm really
pleased that
it's a huge undertaking by the way right
so even having
to get reliability to where it needs to
be we have to have fleets of robots that
we're just operating 24 7 in our offices
to go find those rare failures and
eliminate them it's just a totally
different kind of activity than the
research activity where you get it to
work you know the one robot you have to
work in a repeatable way you know at the
at the high stakes demo it's just very
different
um but I think we're making remarkable
progress against it so one of the cool
things I got a chance to visit Boston
Dynamics and I mean
one of the things that's really cool is
to see a large number of robots moving
about
because I think one of the things you
notice in the research environment is
the MIT for example I don't think anyone
ever has a working robot for prolonged
exactly so like most robots are just
sitting there in a sad
state of despair waiting to be born
brought to life for a brief moment of
time just to have I just I just remember
there's like a there's a spot robot just
I I had like a cowboy hat on it was just
walking randomly for whatever reason I
don't even know but there's a kind of a
sense of sentience to it because it
doesn't seem like anybody was
supervising it it was just doing it I'm
gonna stop way short of the sentience
um it is the case that if you come to
our office you know today and walk
around the hallways
um you're gonna see a dozen robots just
kind of walking around yes all the time
and that's really a reliability test for
us so we have these robots programmed to
do autonomous missions get up off their
charging dock walk around the building
collect data at a few different places
and go sit back down and we want that to
be a very reliable process because
that's what somebody who's running a a
brewery a factory that's what they need
the robot to do so we have to we have to
dog food our own robot we have to test
it in that way and um so on a weekly
basis we have robots that are accruing
something like
um 1500 or maybe 2000 kilometers of
walking
and uh you know over a thousand hours of
operation every week and that's
something that almost I don't think
anybody else in the world can do because
hey you have to have a fleet of robots
to just accrue that much information
you have to be willing to dedicate it to
that test and uh so that's but that's
essential that's how you get the
reliability that's how you get it what
about some of the cost cutting from the
from the manufacture side what have you
learned from the manufacture side of the
transition from r d and we're still
we're still learning a lot there
um we're learning how to cast Parts in
Solo instead of Mill it all out of you
know Billet aluminum
um we're learning how to get plastic
molded parts for and we're learning
about how to control that process so
that you can build the same robot twice
in a row there's a lot to learn there
and we're only part way through that
process
we've set up a manufacturing facility in
Waltham it's about a mile from our
headquarters and we're doing final
assembly and test of both spots and
stretches you know at that factory
and um
and it's hard because to be honest we're
still iterating on the design of the
robot as we find failures from these
reliability tests we need to go engineer
changes and those changes need to now be
propagated to the manufacturing line and
that's a hard process especially when
you want to move as fast as we do
and that's been
challenging and it makes it you know the
folks who are working supply chain who
are trying to get the cheapest parts for
us kind of requires that you buy a lot
of them to make them cheap and then we
go change the design from underneath
them and they're like what are you doing
and so you know getting everybody on the
same page here that it yep we still need
to move fast but we also need to try to
figure out how to reduce cost that's one
of the challenges of of this migration
we're going through and over the past
few years challenges to the supply chain
I mean I imagine you've been a part of a
bunch of stressful meetings yeah things
got more expensive and harder to get and
yeah so it's it's all been a challenge
is there still room for simplification
oh yeah much more and you know these are
really just the first generation of
these machines we're already thinking
about what the next generation of spots
going to look like
spot was built as a platform so you
could put almost any sensor on it you
know we provided data Communications
mechanical connections uh Power
connections
and but for example in the applications
that we're excited about where you're
you're monitoring these factories for
their health
there's probably a simpler machine that
we could build that's really focused on
that use case and that's the difference
between the general purpose machine or
the platform versus the purpose-built
machine and so even though even in the
factory we'd still like the robot to do
lots of different tasks if it's if we
really knew on day one that we're going
to be operating in a factory with these
three sensors in it we would have it all
integrated in a package that would be
easier more less expensive and more
reliable so we're contemplating building
you know a next generation of that
machine so she mentioned that there's a
spot
for people who somehow are not familiar
so it's a yellow robotic dog
and
um has been featured in many Dance
videos it also has gained an arm
so what can you say about the arm that
spot has about the challenges of this
design
and the manufacture of it we think the
future of mobile robots is mobile
manipulation that's where
you know in the past 10 years
it was getting Mobility to work getting
the legged locomotional work if you ask
what's the hard problem in the next 10
years
it's getting a mobile robot to do useful
manipulation for you
and so we wanted spot to have an arm to
experiment with those problems
and the arm is
um
almost as complex as the robot itself
you know and it's a it's an attachable
payload
um it has you know several Motors and
actuators and sensors it has a camera in
the end of its hand so you know you can
sort of see something
the and the robot will control the
motion of its hand to go pick it up
autonomously so in the same way the
robot walks and balances managing its
own foot placement to stay balanced we
want manipulation to be mostly
autonomous where the robot you indicate
okay go grab that bottle and then the
robot will just go do it using the
camera in its hand and then sort of
closing in on that
um the grasp
but it's it's a whole nother complex
robot on top of a complex legged robot
and so and of course we made it the hand
look a little like a head you know
because again we want it to be sort of
identifiable in the last year
um a lot of our sales have been people
who already have a robot now buying an
arm to add to that robot oh interesting
and so the the armor is for sale oh yeah
oh yeah it's an option what's the what's
the interface like to work with the arm
like a is it pretty so are they designed
primarily I guess just ask that question
in general about robots from Boston
Dynamics is it designed to be
easily and efficiently operated remotely
by a human being or is there also the
capability to push towards autonomy
we want both
uh in the next version of the software
that we release uh which will be version
3.3 we're going to offer the ability of
if you have a autonomous mission for the
robot we're going to include the option
that it can go through a door which
means it's going to have to have an arm
and it's gonna have to use that arm to
open the door
and so that'll be an autonomous
manipulation task that just you can
program easily uh with the robot
strictly through you know we have a
tablet interface and so on the tablet
you know you sort of see the The View
that spot sees you say there's the door
handle you know the hinges are on the
left and it opens in the rest is up to
you take care so it just takes care of
everything yeah so we we want in for a
task like opening doors you can automate
most of that and we've automated a few
other tasks uh we had a customer
who had a a high-powered breaker switch
essentially it's an electric utility
Ontario power generation
and they have to when they're going to
disconnect you know their power supply
right that could be a gas generator
could be a nuclear power plant you know
from the grid you have to disconnect
this breaker switch as you can imagine
there's you know hundreds or thousands
of amps and volts involved in this
breaker switch
and it's a dangerous event because
occasionally you'll get what's called an
arc flash as you just do this disconnect
the power the Sparks jump across and
people die doing this
and so uh Ontario power generation used
our spot in in the arm through the
interface to to operate this this
disconnect
um that's right in an interactive way
and they showed it to us
and we were so excited about it and said
you know I bet we can automate that task
and so we we got some examples of that
breaker switch and I believe in the next
generation of software now we're going
to deliver back to Ontario power
generation they're going to be able to
just point the robot
at that breaker they'll indicate that's
the switch there's sort of two actions
you have to do you have to flip up this
little cover press a button then get a
ratchet stick it in to a socket and
literally unscrew this giant breaker
switch so there's a bunch of different
tasks and we basically automated them so
that the human says okay there's the
switch go do that part
that right there is the socket where
you're going to put your tool and you're
going to open it up and so you can
remotely sort of indicate this on the a
tablet and then the robot just does
everything in between and it does
everything all the coordinated movement
of all the different actuators that
includes the body and it maintains its
balance it it walks itself you know into
position so it's within reach and the
arm is in a position where it can do the
whole task so it manages uh the whole
body so how does one become a big enough
customer to request features because I
personally want a robot that gets me
beer
I mean that has to be like one of the
most requests I suppose in the
industrial setting that's uh a
non-alcoholic beverage
um of picking up objects and bringing
the objects to you we love working with
customers who have challenging problems
like this and and this one in particular
because we felt like
what they were doing a it was a safety
feature B we saw that the robot could do
it because they they tele operated it
the first time probably took him an hour
to do it the first time right but the
robot was clearly capable and we thought
oh this is a great problem for us to
work on to figure out how to automate a
manipulation task and so we took it on
not not because we were going to make a
bunch of money from it and selling the
robot back to them but because it
motivated us to go solve what we saw as
the next logical step but many of our
customers in fact uh we we try to our
bigger customers who typically ones who
are going to run a utility or a factory
or something like that we take that kind
of direction from them and if they're
especially if they're going to buy 10 or
20 or 30 robots and they say I really
needed to do this well that's exactly
the right kind of problem that we want
to be working on and so note to self buy
10 spots
and aggressively pushed for beer
manipulation
I think it's